die diskriminierung also gerade heute
zum internationalen hit ist ganz ganz
großes problem dass er die
diskriminierung von vielen menschen eher
wieder zunimmt wir sind gerade dabei die
rolle rückwärts zu machen und erleben
gerade in berlin hat das im vergleich
zum vorjahr ein anstieg wieder 100
angezeigte fälle nämlich auf über 520
fälle
gewalt gegen
tiere menschen gegeben und das ist
sicherlich auch ein grund durch internet
mobbing und so weiter aber die ikone
pandemie hat dazu geführt dass
schutzräume für tiere menschen verloren
gegangen sind und dass heutzutage oder
wir immer noch damit leben müssen dass
viele schutzräume weggefallen sind und
nicht mein für mich als privilegierten
schwulen mann ist es sicherlich kein
problem wenn sie jetzt irgendwie den
klub nicht mehr geht aber eben für eine
transfusion oder eben für
lesbische frauen junge
schwule trans menschen kiosks dass da
schutzräume wegfallen durch die pandemie
weggefallen sind aber sicherlich jetzt
auch wir einfach ein anstieg der
diskriminierung wir erleben dass gerade
in den öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
stattfindet das ist sicherlich ein
großes problem und deswegen engagiere
ich mich auch im berliner csd ev und
weiß dass es wichtig ist weiterhin auf
die straße zu gehen auch wenn mir immer
bewusst ist dass ich als privilegierter
schwuler mann da überhaupt keine
probleme mehr erleben wer ist der nicht
privilegiert
ich würde interessieren wir können sie
uns irgendetwas sagen über die frage wer
sind die täter also wir sagen wenn man
wenn man also die reine statistik jetzt
irgendwie anstieg von von straftaten ich
habe mich gerade gefragt sozusagen
erstmal wie inwiefern spielt corona
sozusagen der verlust von schutzräumen
wir waren alle in quarantäne oder ein
bisschen es hat gar nicht stattgefunden
also wer sind denn die täter durch
welche täter steigen denn die zahlen an
also wenn ich halt nicht mehr in denen
in den klub gehen kann also in den
nehmen wir mal das schmutz in berlin was
ja dann über zwei jahre auch
größtenteils geschlossen war wo man eben
früher sich einfach besser
ausleben konnte ist das halt heute hat
es halt alles zu hause stattgefunden und
so wie ich das von der polizei
statistiker werden auch von der berliner
polizei gehört habe sind auch daneben
diskriminierungen und angriffe zu hause
nachbarschaftsverhältnis extrem
angestiegen oder eben passiert ja weil
es eben immer noch nicht
selbstverständlich wenn nebenan das
lesbische paar wohnt wir tun immer alle
so also dass der gang damit ihr ja ja
das aber ist fragen sie mal bei der
polizei
ich bin hier wirklich bin wirklich ich
bin 84 nach berlin gezogen bei meiner
damaligen freund nebenan wohnte ein
zwillingspaar das lesbisch war die
hatten zwei große doggen gewohnten
autoren der zwei zimmer wurde und kein
mensch hat sich
1986 darüber aufgeregt ist es war mitten
in berlin in charlottenburg
trotzdem waren waren waren diejenigen
die um es sexuell waren lesbische
weniger damals glaube ich etwas
militanter weil sie weitaus mehr für
ihre rechte kämpfen müssen sie jetzt
sagen das ist heute immer noch so als es
heute der fall ist wo es eine große
gesellschaftliche oder in anderen
regionen hängen da im stadtwald ist es
ja immer noch schlimm in pirmasens auch
wenn man sagt ich bin schwul und
händchenhaltend durch die straßen gibt
gleichgeschlechtlich aber in berlin
mag es so viele übergriffe geben
vielleicht aber auch weil sich mehr
menschen öffentlich dazu bekennen es
kann ja auch daran liegen wie wir sonst
nicht reden es ist nicht akzeptabel wenn
das so ist nur es hat sich doch auch
viel getan in den letzten aber sie reden
sogar klein mit ihrem einen guten
beispiel das mag auch sein dass das so
ist also ich als thüringer hat meine
erste diskriminierung tatsächlich nicht
auf dem land in thüringen
erlebt ich bin aus saalfeld sondern als
ich mit 16 nach berlin kam und eine
ausbildung zum einzelhandelskaufmann
gemacht habe in einem warenhaus da saß
ich dann irgendwann bei der
personalchefin im büro hinter mir wurde
zu geschlossen und dann hat sie mich
zusammen mit dem abteilungsleiter sehr
in die mangel genommen
ich hätte doch hiv und was überhaupt
nicht stimmt ja und das mit 16 ich hatte
damals zum glück schon mein freund der
heute mein ehemann ist worüber ich eben
sehr froh bin dass das endlich möglich
ist und auch dazu sagen ich
gehe erst 217 wirklich möglich war ist
ja nun auch immer man hat ja nun lange
gedauert aber ich wollte
diese das wasser eine der wenigen
diskriminierung damit bin ich bei dieser
bei dieser privilegierung und um das
zelt zu sagen ich kann mich halt
verteidigen und ja maskulin toxic mich
kein sport bin werde ich halt nicht
angegriffen aber sobald jemand da
schwächer wird oder eben auch nur
annährend feminin ist als man dann wird
er eben des krimi einmal eine sache
möchte mit einem mal reinschauen das ist
ja und zwar das was gerade auch schon
angesprochen wurde von béla anda mit dem
video wo sie auf merkel getroffen sind
das haben sie eigentlich gerade auch
schon selbst mit der eheschließung fast
angesprochen habe rein da einmal ganz
kurz rein
wann darf ich meinem freund irgendwann
ihr mann nennen wenn ich ihn höre
[Musik]
ich kenne bei mir in der cdu und
schließe mich gleich mit 1 viele die
sich sehr viele gedanken über dieses
thema machen die längste sagen da wären
die gleichen werte gelebt und trotzdem
irgendwo vielleicht aufgewachsen sind
neben gefühl mann und frau das ist eben
die ehe wie wir sie kennen und das
andere ist eine genau so wertvolle
partnerschaft bei frau merkel
antwort für sie diskriminierend als sie
gehört haben
sie hat ja ein beispiel
oder sie hat ja sehr gut erklärt wie sie
ihre einstellung dazu verändert hat ja
ich meine ich bin danach spießruten
gelaufen als ich gesagt habe dass ich
dass ich sie mag oder ja da gesagt dass
ich ein fan von chaplin also ich mochte
sie ja über viele strecken sehr gern in
den dingen die sie gemacht hat und eben
dieses zuzugeben ich habe da einen
wandel durchgemacht über die zeit gehabt
nicht eines besseren belehren lassen das
will ich ja von den menschen das ist ja
das was ich auch in meiner heimat
erreichen will oder das mit den menschen
wenn ich auf die straße gehe erreichen
will dass sich durch das was ich mache
den menschen eben ihre berührungsängste
nehmen und sie dadurch aufkläre weil ich
nur glaube reicht nur an bildung glaube
dass ist das einzige womit wir die
menschen weiter bringen aber trotzdem
hat sie mich insofern diskriminiert dass
am ende dagegen gestimmt hat und
deswegen nicht mit der antwort die war
vier minuten lang wie immer von frau
merkel und keiner hat sie verstanden
aber dass sie dann drei tage später im
bundestag hat dagegen gestimmt hat das
mag parteipolitisch nachvollziehbar
gewesen sein aber es hat mich trotzdem
enttäuscht nachdem sie so ausführlich
erklärt warum sie heute eben ist
unterstützt aber vielleicht kann man
doch auch als ich mich stört eigentlich
nur der begriff diskriminierung wissen
sie es kann unterschiedliche meinungen
geben zum thema er ich zum beispiel habe
ein gründliches verständnis
es gibt ein muslimisches ehe verständnis
dass geht davon aus dass man irgendwie
mehrere frauen haben das lehne ich auch
ab ich kann wertschätzen ich war auch
mal in der sendung mit mit zwei
bezaubernden 70-jährigen herren zu einer
schule spa die seit 50 jahren zusammen
waren und so die waren wirklich sehr süß
wo ich sagen würde die haben die haben
es geschafft quasi 50 jahre zusammen zu
bleiben was eine großartige leistung ist
und das kann dich wertschätzen beiden
familien nicht mehr verdient als zum
beispiel leute die vielleicht zwei jahre
zusammen sind aber nicht gleich
geschlecht aber ist in den sog sagt er
etwas was man sich verdient
sie sich anfühlt nur klar ist das ist
mein partner das ist mein eingetragener
lebenspartner sie wissen ja nicht wie
sich das anfühlt das nur sagen zu können
das war die einzige möglichkeit die wir
hatten das ist mein freund können paare
nach ihm sagen dass man nein konnte ich
eben nicht es war eben nicht mein
ehemann ich konnte es halt nicht sagen
weil ich mir das gesetz weil weil mir
das gesetz ist verboten hat es ist jetzt
ein bisschen
dass man rechtlich konnte sich also dass
mir das jemand sagt ja irgendwie
justiz macht das ist natürlich dann also
ich konnte es halt nicht ich konnte es
nicht sagen und deswegen hat frau merkel
das gefragt und dass sie dieses
verständnis dann aufgebaut hat und
gesagt okay alles klar wir geben das
jetzt in die offene abstimmung das war
ja auch toll zwar auch alles ein riesen
zu fall und es war wahlkampf was mich an
eben auch sagen ja aber trotzdem war es
längst überfällig weil andere länder
aber da so zu tun als ob das jetzt
irgendwie alles dann selbstverständlich
ist ich meine wir sehen doch die rolle
rückwärts stefan prantner von der
thüringer fdp hat danach antrag gestellt
dass das wieder rückgängig gemacht wird
und nicht erlebe heute selbst in meiner
familie dass diese partei gewählt wird
dann wird sich meine er wieder hinten an
gestellt wird weil sie nicht so wichtig
ist wie irgendwie andere themen dann
muss ich sagen das betrifft sie denn
vielleicht irgendwie nicht ob man
ehemann oder ehefrau sagen kann aber mir
war es halt wichtig dass ich das sagen
kann ich bin heute 16 jahren mit meinen
partnern zusammen und sehr stolz darauf
was man sagen toll das können viele von
sich nicht sagen aber immer noch um den
ernsthaften punkt dazu gemeint da haben
sie wirklich land viele und sie mache
ich jetzt als gemeinde als gemeinde von
von als interessenvertreter viel für
gekämpft weltweit für gekämpft und wer
ist eine errungenschaft dieser nicht
wieder genommen werden ich finde das ist
auch ein legal ist
ziel von ihnen gewesen und das ist auch
egal in dem sinne das ist auf jeden fall
jetzt legalisiert worden ist und das
sollte man ihnen auch nicht wieder
nehmen und jede tendenz dahin ist falsch
und das soll gewahrt bleiben dass man
nicht schon
und ich kann auch nicht verstehen wenn
sich parteien oder minderheiten dagegen
stellen denn das ist ein begehrter genau
sitzt unserer gesellschaft und sich den
rechten die wir eben auch anderen
gruppen geben müssen wie alles andere
auch jetzt haben wir ja die ehe und das
ist gut es geht mir heute darum warum
ich auf die straße gehe ist wenn mir
heute eine drag-queen sagt dass sie sich
vor zehn jahren wohl gefühlt hat in der
u bahn zur party zu fahren und heute ist
auf gar keinen fall mehr machen würde
sondern maximal mit dem taxi dahin fährt
aufgedeckt dann macht mir das doch
sorgen was ist denn da passiert in den
letzten 20 jahren warum das warum ging
das vor zehn jahren warum geht es heute
nicht mehr ich habe die antwort darauf
nicht ich kann ihnen garantieren dass
schwule freunde aus köln geben die sagen
das täterprofil hat sich einfach
verändert in köln haben sie ja genau das
selbe problem auch die schwulenszene war
völlig ist alles war völlig in ordnung
man es ist eine liberale stadt
trossingen und große schwulenszene in
köln und inzwischen hat man einfach ein
größeres problem seit vielen jahren mit
muslimischen minderheiten das ist das
problem das heißt wir haben quasi eine
neue schwulenfeindlichkeit die
eigentlich gar nicht sozusagen aus
unserer gesellschaft kommt unseren die
tatsächlich weil sie durch ein ganzes
ein anderes geschlechterbild und auch
ein ganz anderes bild auf homosexualität
kommt und das ist ein muslimisches bild
und damit müssen wir uns
auseinandersetzen das macht überhaupt
keinen sinn dass totzuschweigen weil
deswegen fragte ich nach den
tätergruppen wir müssen wir müssen dann
wieder dorthin zurück dass man eben dass
auch sie in ruhe über die straße gehen
können ohne dass sie angegriffen werden
aber dafür müssen wir eben auch benennen
wer die täter sind damit wir uns auch
diese täter vornehmen und nicht so
pauschal so nach dem motto wir haben ein
rückschritt wir haben dich rückschritte
wir haben bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen
die da ein problem mit haben und mit
denen bis in uns befassen ja und
gleichzeitig haben wir euch ja aus der
afb das ist plötzlich wieder in ordnung
natürlich und das können sie jetzt auch
als wurde bot ist aber trotzdem
kommen sonst gar nichts
[Musik]
aber ich wollte das auch ergänzen ich
glaube man dass es richtig was sie sagen
mit den muslimen das ist so statistisch
gesehen aber es ist natürlich auch
wichtig dass die afg eine reaktionäre
partei ist und deshalb der auffassung
ist dass man keine homosexuellen paare
braucht also das muss man auch ganz klar
so sehen und ich meine die afg bekämpfen
wir auch aus anderen gründen politisch
aber man muss sie auch mit ihrem
weltbild bekämpfen das ist so und es
wird immer wieder parteien geben die
sagen wir müssen hier in reutberg machen
wir haben das gesellschaftliche beck
sehen wir ja in einer ganz anderen art
und weise in den usa da waren sie ja und
diese teilung der gesellschaft da kommen
wir gleich noch drauf die wir haben
sowohl also verschärft in den usa aber
inzwischen eben auch in deutschland die
bezieht ja solche themen mit ein wir
haben in den usa es wieder eine debatte
der schwangerschaftsabbruch bei frauen
verboten werden soll hätten wir jedoch
auch nicht geglaubt dass das geht und
wir haben diese ganzen evangelen
evangelikalen die ganz klar sagen dass
homosexuelle beziehungen nicht gehen und
da muss man natürlich aufpassen und
deswegen das ist richtig was sie sagen
afd ist richtig andere tendenzen in der
gesellschaft ist richtig dass wir durch
corona eine größere menge von menschen
haben die nicht wir sondern quer denken
ist auch richtig und da fällt so was
dann auch manchmal mit rein also ich
glaube es ist ein konglomerat und das
gilt es zu benennen und es gilt was
dagegen zu tun gesellschaftlich
für mich entschieden nicht mit dem
finger auf eine gruppe zu zeigen sondern
hat für mich entschieden ich engagiere
mich da lieber und gehe auf
religionsgruppen zu säen atis von der
moschee ich gehe auf bernd höcker von
der evangelischen kirche zu ich gehe auf
den cash at vereinen der jüdischen
vereinigung für homosexuelle zu ich gehe
auf diese leute zu verbinden sie
miteinander oder sie verbinden sich
schon selbst miteinander es gibt jeden
jedes jahr vor dem csd auch ein einen
gottesdienst für alle religiösen gruppen
und da muss dann aufklärung stattfinden
natürlich ist da überall viel zu tun
aber das ist doch in der katholischen
kirche nicht anders also ich meine
mit dem finger auf einen